okay guys
part three of my evening tea thoughts
now I'm sorry I'm a little busted right
now
I'm sorry this is a more articulate and
I'm sorry that I've taken you through
not one not two but three videos before
I tell you the craziest thing that's
happened to me in my life
today
not today yesterday I was messaged by a
comedian
and this comedian
I forgot what he said I forgot what his
opening message was but he had a blue
check mark and I have a rule and I know
you guys will be like the hypergamous
women in here but like look I have a
rule that I always respond to Blue
checks or anyone that has over like 50
000 100 000 followers guy or girl if I
missed any
I'm sorry but I just tried if I see him
I try to because you never know on
Instagram who's on the other end and you
never know what opportunities on the
other end so messages in general even
like people without a lot of followers
if I just think they have a decent
amount of followers or they seem
interesting or just have an interesting
idea I'll respond and be like oh tell me
more about it you never know
now now
this comedian mentions that he's going
to be in London and he says I opened for
Dave Chappelle do you want to go to one
of our shows now me
I think Dave Chappelle is hilarious so
I'm like yeah I want to go but
didn't hear from him for a couple days
so I was like
maybe he's just gas and like who knows
anyways so
yesterday I got a message today says the
show's tonight do you want to come now
me
I already was having my friend cover a
show for me
I wanted a Saturday off now
because of this I said hell yeah
hell yeah let's go so I brought my
friend Ally and we both go to the show
now this show's funny it was front row
to Dave Chappelle it was hilarious I had
a great time to take away your phones
which is fine I actually liked it more
because it makes you pay attention I
don't have to worry about who's texting
me nothing
and I'm looking at the
thing now after it he says do you guys
want to go to this place after it's like
a restaurant bar type thing and I'm
thinking with like all the comedians
from the show and I'm like oh my God
that's freaking lit hell yeah I want to
go hell yeah this is I have never dealt
with famous people in my life in my life
so I'm like
this is what a time to be alive I could
ask people to come on my show I could do
whatever like it was just an exciting
day so I go and we go into the back door
of this place because I think because
he's famous like
um I don't know so and I walk in the
back door with the some of the comedians
that open not date and Dave walks in the
back and he looks at me and he's like
I've seen you on YouTube
what
you see me on YouTube
stop it stop it I was like I swear to
God I was very polite I said oh wow
thank you but in my head I was like
I'm goaded
I'm going in and he's like yeah it's
really surreal seeing you in real life
now
um there's a couple people that were
also at this event
now
I don't know if I should say this on
camera because now they won't see it
they won't see it
um so
there's a couple other people that I saw
now I'm gonna be honest guys there's
people that I don't know
and they're very famous and I don't know
but one of them that I got to meet too
was Eric Erica Badu
and I don't know who she was but every
person I've said that to
I shook your hand every person that I
said that to was like wow
she's really famous that's like so lit
she's the goat and I looked her up she's
got some lit songs
I'm so sorry Eric I really I highly
doubt she'll see this but
and then there was
um
I mean it says other model like this
really famous model there and I'd heard
she was in a Kanye song
Naomi Campbell Naomi Campbell and it was
so cool guys and okay every time I've
rated someone one to ten I'd also like
to say these are the most beautiful
beautiful people I've seen in a room in
my life that were at this like party
stunning I've decided that every girl
that I've rated one to ten I need you to
knock yourself a point down knock
yourself a point down because I
I have seen
a real eight nine and ten now going in
that room
and it's none of y'all nobody that's
come on the show I've seen the real
girls that the models look like and now
I understand Captain Samuel's scale and
why he was so harsh because I've seen
the real people and it's nobody that I
know in real life I was definitely
yeah um
so it was just crazy because yesterday I
woke up I thought it was going to be a
normal day and I ended up that Dave
knows who I am
what
and that's the crazy thing about YouTube
you never know who's at the other end of
the screen and there could just be
someone watching
that
you know I don't know so
yeah that's my story that's my crazy
story
um
he was really cool he was actually so
nice he was so nice everyone was so nice
and I had a lot of fun
and
that's it that's that's the crazy thing
that happened to me anyways
um like the video
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time